on parle de la loi immigration sans
grande surprise c'est un petit peu le
feuilleton de la semaine Quentin on est
à 3 jours de la commission mixte
paritaire où députés et sénateurs vont
donc essayer de s'entendre sur une
version commune du projet de loi
immigration et les tractations se
multiplient voilà avec une personne au
cœur de ces tractations c'est ellisabeth
borne depuis le rejet lundi
effectivement du texte à l'Assemblée
nationale le calendrier de la première
ministre a été complètement chamboulé
les réunions ahet Tigon se multiplient
les cadres Renaissance étaient reçus
hier dans l'après-midi à l'image des
rapporteurs que l'on voit à l'image ici
sont les députés également Sacha Houlier
le président renaissance de la de de la
commission des lois de l'Assemblée
nationale les LR ont même été reçus deux
fois signé qu'Élisabeth borne essaie
bien de nouer un accord avec ses
parlementaires de droite Bruno retaillot
était ainsi reçu à Matignon mercredi
midi et à nouveau hier matin à 8h30
d'autres réunions ont également été
ajouté avec les ministres concernés hier
soir avec les chefs de fil Renaissance
également et entre les Parlement a eux
même écoutez à notre micro la rapporteur
LR pour le Sénat Mel Jord qui recevait
ses collègues hier de l'Assemblée
écoutez les discussions se poursuivent
effectivement et je dois moi-même
rencontrer cet après-midi mes collègues
rapporteurs de l'Assemblée nationale
donc nous allons nous allons également
échanger cet après-midi dans des
conditions un peu particulières puisque
nous avons un texte le texte du Sénat et
qu'il n'ont rien puisque aucun texte n'a
été voté à l'Assemblée nationale
qu'est-ce que ça dit le fait que
ellisabeth borne a repris le dossier en
main et reçoiv efftivement vos chefs de
fil au à matigon qu'est-ce que ça dit oh
bah ça dénote sans doute d'un souhait
qui est vraissemblablement un souhait
présidentiel de de trouver un accord et
d'avoir d'avoir un texte sur sur
l'immigration qui est un sujet majeur
voilà les réunions qui vont continuer
avec une dernière réunion qui est déjà
prévue pour dimanche soir entre les
chefs de fil LR et la première
ministretigon ce feuilleton depuis la
motion de Roget lundi c'est ellisabeth
Bor qui reprend la main clairement
Arnaud bah oui apparemment clairement
alors ceci dit ça fait ça ça relève le
niveau de responsabilité ça met la
première ministre en première ligne
après que le ministre de l'Intérieur ait
subi un revers que d'aucun considérait
comme inattendu mais qui ne l'était pas
forcément d'ailleurs au regard de
l'arithmétique parlementaire au regard
surtout de la dynamique de discussion du
texte entre le Sénat et l'Assemblée
parce que finalement le vrai problème
c'était quoi quelle était la vraie
version de ce texte pour Monsieur
Darmanin est-ce que c'était la version
qui avait été votée au Sénat ou est-ce
que ça avait été la version qui avait
été votée par la commission des lois qui
détricotait la plupart des dispositions
telles qu'elles avaient été votées au
Sénat donc il y avait si vous voulez une
ambigué quasiment fondatrice qui
explique finalement la position des
républicains à l'Assemblée nationale ce
qu'il faut noter aussi dans cette
affaire parce qu'on l'a un peu oublié
mais la la position initiale du groupe
LR à l'Assemblée nationale était déjà
plus dure que la position de la majorité
sénatoriale et notamment également du
groupe LR au Sénat donc ça va également
peser on peut l'imaginer dans les
discussions au sein de la CMP dans ce ce
lundi ouais c'est ellisabeth borne qui
est maître d'œuvre maintenant Dominique
est-ce que du coup elle joue gros la
première ministre indiscutablement elle
joue gros elle joue son siège euh
comment aurait-il été possible que ce
soit pas elle qui soit mise par Emmanuel
Macron en en première ligne les premièr
ministre mais par ailleurs pardonnez-moi
mais a des guillemets la cartouche
d'armanin est grillée je veux dire il a
il a échoué il a été sincère il s'est
lancé en avant il avait des
arrière-pensées c'est son droit
d'ailleurs personnel politique et tout
derrière tout ça mais il a complètement
échouéi il y a il y a derrière tout ce
qui se passe là un me semble-t-il un
petit parfum je je pas être démago et
antiparlementariste mais un petit parfum
4e République he je veux dire les les
Français qui suivent ça on va se
retrouver avec quelques-uns à à 8h à 10h
à minuit et peut-être qu'au dernier
moment à l'arracher on va obtenir
quelque chose il y a un petit parfum 4e
République qui n'est qui c'est c'est pas
bon c'est pas bon pour les
parlementaires en général et puis il y a
autre chose qui est un enjeu politique
rien ne prouve que ça va cette fois sous
l'égide des d'Élisabeth borne que ça va
cette fois passer autrement dit on est
parti d'un petit texte qui a été lu de
part et d'autre de façon ambigu chacun
avait sa lecture et elle était
contradictoire de celle des autres et on
est dans une situation que la plupart
des français on la tête à toute autre
chose aujourd'hui bien entendu mais on
est dans une situation où ça peut mal
tourner ça peut mal tourner et avoir des
conséquences politique forte
elle joue vous m'avez posé la question
elle la réponse joue gros euh elle joue
très gros ouais et et ça crée des
tensions au sein du gouvernement aussi
Quenin voilà la presse ce matin et qui
rapporte effectivement une réunion qui a
été houleuse hier entre plusieurs
ministres et notamment Gérald Darmanin
et Franck rester qui ont assuré qu'ils
auraient une majorité en cas d'accord de
la CMP pour la faire adopt par
l'Assemblée nationale et d'autres
ministres qui ont dit que c'était déjà
la promesse faite lors de l'examen la
semaine au début de la semaine et que et
bien il fallait qu'il se méfi de cette
assurance qu'ils avaient d'AV une
majorité derrière leur texte oui parce
que quand bien même il y a un accord ça
c'est pas fait on va y venir derrière il
faudrait le faire passer à l'Assemblée
national donc le faire passer par l'aile
gauche de la majorité est-ce que les
tensions peuvent perdurer ou est-ce que
si sachaoulier qui est en commission des
lois qui est un peu le chef de l'ail
gauche valide l'accord et bien ça suivra
forcément derrière oui vous avez raison
de parler de sa choulier parce qu'il
porte une responsabilité non négligeable
dans l'échec de Monsieur Darmanin parce
que c'est lui qui présidait la
commission des lois et c'est la
commission des lois qui a quand même
complètement vidé de sa substance le
texte qu'il avait été voté par le Sénat
et d'ailleurs je suis étonné que
personne au sein de la majorité ne
mettre pas un peu je vais dire de
Monsieur sachaoulier devant ses propres
responsabilités enfin en tout cas moi je
serai parlementaire je ne le suis pas
fort heureusement mais en l'occurrence
je lui poserai un certain nombre de
questions mais la vérité si vous voulez
le problème c'est que ce texte à mon
sens ne peut pas passer s'il n'y a pas
l'apport des voix des républicains c'est
là qu'il y a le plus gros réservoir de
voix en fait il y a un calcul
coûtbénéfice est-ce qu'on perd plus à
gauche ou est-ce qu'on gagne plus à
droite aujourd'hui manifestement quand
même le calcul qui semble être fait
après notamment la motion de Roget
l'adoption de la motion de Roget à
l'Assemblée nationale c'est de
considérer que si il y a des réservoirs
de voix parlementaires elles sont plutôt
du côté des LR d'autant plus que quand
même je le rappelle avant que ce texte
soit discuté en commission des lois vous
aviez une quinzaine de parlementaires LR
qui disaient qu'ils étaient prêts à le
le voter donc ils avaient plutôt une
attitude bienveillante vis-à-vis de ce
texte mais c'est encore une fois la
discussion telle qu'elle s'est déroulée
à la commission des lois qui a vrai
semblblement gripper le système après
moi je sais pas quel est le poids de
l'ail gauche de la majorité au sein de
la majorité lui il revendique 40 à 50
députés je je lui revendique je oui
peut-être je ne sais pas mais est-ce
qu'ils vont aller jusque je veut dire
c'est pour eux quand même prendre une
responsabilité qui est considérable ça
veut dire que concrètement si ce texte
n'est pas adopté euh ou si sont obligés
de passer par le 493 avec le risque
cette fois-ci d'une motion de censure
qui plus est c'est quand même l'avenir
même de la majorité très relative euh de
de de de de de Madame borne qui est en
jeu à l'Assemblée nationale est-ce qu'on
va jusqu'au bout de cette logique de
crise en effet c'est une question qui va
se poser rapidement si l'elle gauche de
la majorité décide de ne pas suivre euh
le gouvernement qui s'entendrait et ce
qui est parfait encore je rejoins ce que
dit Dominique c'est-à-dire
qu'aujourd'hui les échos qu'on a sur la
CMP c'est qu'on est très loin du but
ouais on on va parler deslr mais au-delà
de son poste joue aussi l'unité de sa
majorité Dominique ah tout à fait je je
partage tout à fait le sentiment de
d'Arnaud bénedetti sur le fait que ce
qu'il est convenu c'est presque la
première fois depuis 2017 qu'à ce
point-là on est tous amenés logiquement
à parler de l'aile gauche de la majorité
elle existe estce que est-ce que c'est
40 50 c'est peut-être généreusement dit
mais enfin il y a une sensibilité c'est
effectivement ce qui est annoncé par
certains qui sont intéressés à à ce
chiffre euh mais il y a effectivement
une sensibilité de gauche ça se résume
me semble-t-il de la façon suivante
est-ce que maintenant avec ellisabeth
borne l'opération qui consiste à
rassembler leslr le gros DLR pas une
minorité deslr le gros DLR et la
majorité dans son unité peut réussir euh
est-ce que ou ou ou alors si elle ne
peut pas réussir où va-t-on c'est c'est
c'est c'est ça le le problème
c'est-à-dire que c'est l'opération
d'armanin
mais géré par la première ministre qui
elle-même est issue des rangs de la
gauche et et peut-être peut trouver mais
attention si les LR parce qu'il faut
aussi insister sur le l'importance et le
rôle des LR là-dedans si le groupe LR
fait monter les enchère énormément il y
a une possibilité que indépendamment de
la supposée gauche de la majorité que
les députés de la majorité disent pas ça
pas moi on va pas faire parce que ce
serait une alliance bonne du forme qui
se dessinerait derrière et justement
Quentin lesair ils font monter les
enchairres hier ils ont écrit à l'Élysée
ils reviennent à la charge avec leur
proposition constitutionnelle exactement
on en parlait d'ailleurs sur ce plateau
la semaine dernière c'est une
information du Figaro Olivier marlex
bruneo retaillot et Eric cotti ont écrit
au Président de la République avec cette
citation dans leur lettre le projet de
loi pour contrôler l'immigration ne
permettra pas de reprendre complètement
le contrôle de notre politique
migratoire écrivent--il et il formule à
nouveau les propositions qu'ils avaient
déjà présenté la semaine dernière avec
leur texte de modification de la
Constitution qui avait échoué he à la
fois avec une une cisure avec les
centristes au Sénat et un vote qui avait
capoté à l'Assemblée nationale on s'en
souvient jeudi mais donc ils refont ses
propositions avec des plafonds
migratoires c'est donc l'idée des quotas
fixés par le Parlement autre mesure cité
dans la lettre le fait que les demandes
d'asile s'effectuent en dehors du
territoire français les LR qui appelle
le président de la République je cite à
ouvrir au plus vite l'urgence chantier
de la révision constitutionnelle alors
un sur le le fond ce chantier de la
révision constitutionnelle on le
rappelle pour le moment il a échoue au
Parlement l'Assemblée nationale lesr ont
dû retirer leur texte en plein examen et
au Sénat ils ont même dû le retirer
avant le début de l'examen du coup
est-ce que c'est opportun de remettre ce
dossier sur la table maintenant Arnaud
ils sont en situation de force dans le
débat parlementaire donc naturellement
il faut monter les les enchères et ils
prennent date aussi parce qu'ils ont pas
tout à fait tort et j'entendais Henry
HUD tout à l'heure précédemment sur ce
plateau de considérer que le texte tel
qu'il va être éventuellement voté y
compris celui du Sénat ne règle pas
fondamentalement l'ensemble des
problèmes qui sont ceux posés par la
politique migratoire et on sait très
bien que si l'on veut véritablement
reprendre la main sur notre politique
migratoire il y a bien évidemment
d'autres sujets qu'il faut aborder dont
celui éventuellement des traités
européens et que ça passe forcément par
une révision constitutionnelle moi je
m'étonne si vous voulez que lors de la
discussion de la niche parlementaire des
LR il y a pas eu de signaux qui a été
envoyé par la majorité ou LR notamment
pas seulement sur le texte concernant la
la proposition de loi constitutionnelle
mais également sur l'accord
franco-algérien dont on sait très bien
qu'il est un point très important dans
la maîtrise de nos flux migratoires
d'ailleurs il y a un certain nombre de
députés horizon dont le président du
groupe parlementaire monsieur marangi
qui ont voté la proposition la
proposition de loi qui était présenté
par LR remettons en question l'accord
franco-algérien donc c'est vrai que
quand même force de force de reconnaître
quand même qu'on est qu'on a pas donné
toutes les cartes qui permettai
d'obtenir un accord sur le texte sur
l'immigration et Géral a même était vif
il a dit c'est un double frxit si vous
voulez changer les règles européennes
vous n'z qu'à gagner les élections
européennes oui bien sûr alors ça sur
cette partie il a été dur mais il a
certainement eu tort d'être dur comme
cela parce que le problème si vous
voulez vous pouvez pas aller chercher
vous pouvez pas aller chercher les voix
DLR et leur dire finalement circuler il
y a rien à voir quant à votre
proposition encore une fois quelle était
la vérité de Monsieur Darmanin sur ce
texte et c'est son échec personnel en
l'occurrence parce qu'il a donné
l'impression d'ossiller entre finalement
deux textes celui du Sénat et celui de
la commission des
lois j'entends ce que dit Arnaud
Benedetti en en soulignant que que les
LR ont raison de faire je je traduis en
raison si j'ai bien compris de de faire
monter les enchères puisqu'ils sont en
position de force j'ai envie de dire oui
pardonnez-moi je me caricature et non
parce que mais attendez les LR mais les
LR c'est quo non non mais attendez moi
je le dis carrément les LR c'est quoi
c'est une minorité active importante
mais attendez on est on est dans la 4e
République enfin c'est absolument
incroyable cette situation alors
attendez on est peut-être dans la 4e
République je redis ce que je ressentais
au au début de notre et ce que j'exprime
mais au début de notre échange ça peut
très très mal tourner c'est non
seulement Elisabeth Bor n'est pas
assurée je je on en est pas là hein mais
je je fais pas je lis pas dans le mar de
café mais n'est pas assuré de rester à
Matignon si les choses se dégradent si
l'accord ne se fait pas mais on est
peut-être en train de voir une situation
qui bah je vais le dire on en est pas là
mais qui pourrait peut-être amener à ce
que les élections président soit
anticipé c'eston jamaison jamais est-ce
qu'ils n'ont pas gros à perdre les
républicains à ne pas trouver d'accord
parce qu'on imagine que l'exécutif ne se
privera pas de les rendre responsables
de l'échec d'un accord en
CMP enfin bon les républicains ont été
très bienveillants depuis le début de
cette législature vis-à-vis
de également je dire il faut rappeler
que quand même si la loi sur les
retraites a été voté c'est grâce c'est
le moins qu'on puisse dire à l'attitude
de la majorité du groupe LR donc on peut
pas il y a eu un 493 parce que les LR
n'avit n'avont pas porté suffisamment de
voix pour que le texte passe 1493 certes
mais enfin globalement quand même c'est
le fait que les LR dans leur immense
majorité au sein du groupe LR décide de
ne pas voter la motion de censure qui
fait que la la loi sur les retraites a
fini par être adoptée donc moi si vous
voulez je pense que il y a par rapport à
l'opinion publique euh l'opinion
publique aujourd'hui quand on regarde
les derniers sondages regardez il y a un
ou deux sondages qui sont sorti
considère je veux dire que est plutôt
favorable à la motion de Roget par
contre ils veulent en effet une solution
une solution de de compromis sur ce
texte parce que il considère que il y a
la nécessité absolue de trouver un
compromis pour avancer compromis n'est
pas un gros mot mais ils sont plutôt sur
la position je regardis un dernier
sondage et des Sondag a que ça ils sont
plutôt sur la position du texte LR tel
qu'il a été voté au Sénat donc en
l'occurrence si vous voulez par rapport
à l'opinion publique il y a intérêt me
semble-il pour le LR de tenir cette
ligne là aujourd'hui un dernier mot
parce que il y a pas que l' LR il y a
aussi au sein de la majorité que
s'attend on en parlait un peu il y en a
un qui s'est fait entendre hier c'est
François Baayou qu'on entendait plus
allié d'Emmanuel Macron l'absence de
débat à l'Assemblée nationale est un
gâchier épouvantable dit-il à quoi
joue-il écoutez françois beayrou est un
personnage important de la 5e République
et de la la marche de l'actuelle
République
il me paraît plus aujourd'hui un
commentateur qu'un acteur décisif arnud
rapidement il fait entendre la voix du
MoDem dans ce
débat entendre plus effic tout à fait
naturel en l'occurrence voilà allez on
suivra tout ça évidemment on en parlera
longuement lundi jour de cette
commission mixte paritaire mais c'est
vendredi on perd pas nos bonnes
habitudes on va découvrir notre
paattimoine et notre addadition on va
mettre un peu d'esprit de Noël avant les
marchés Quentin rassurez-vous Noël qui
arrive à grand pas plus que 10 jours et
qui dit esprit de Noël dit illumination
au tiet dans le valdoise la mairie a
lancé un concours entre les habitants et
Jonathan dupriaas nous y emmène dans le
minibus du jury au Tillet dans le
valdoise la brigade de Noël est sur le
pont dans ce minibus cette petite équipe
d'élus municipaux s'élance pour une
tournée des pavillons
[Musique]
illuminés pour les fêtes la commune a
lancé un grand concours Daniel et les
autres forment le jury chargé de noter
les participants alors les critère c'est
l'esprit de Noël le premier deuxè c'est
l'harmonie je crois c'est ça 3è
originalé et note personnelle du J et
notre personnelle du jury pour Daniel ce
qui fera la différence c'est la présence
du fameux esprit de Noël l'esprit de
Noël moi c'est Père Noël des
sapins premierère arrêt chez
Marie-Hélène derrière
c'est une habituée qui participe tous
les ans par amour de la magie de Noël
c'est la lumière c'est la déco c'est les
réunion de famille c'est c'est tout un
état d'esprit ici les illuminations
électriques côtoi de petits ornements
confectionnés à base de matériaux
recyclés Daniel est plutôt conquis il y
a beaucoup
de d'objets de récupération qu''s ont
mis en valeur et j'ai trouvé ça sympa
mais pas de temps à perdre pour le jury
un sérieux prétendant à la victoire les
attend bonsoir Alain a mis le paquet
dans son jardin cette année des
illuminations totalement étanches grâce
à un ingénieux système dissimulé dans
cette église
ça c'est un bah c'est le toit qui
s'ouvre qui permet justement d'avoir une
certaine étanchéité au niveau des des
des raccordement électrique autrement
bah ça Dijon c'est un sacré boulot ah
bah c'est il faut ce qu'il faut c'est
Noël quand même allons la tournée se
poursuit direction le centre commercial
où les attend Maria la coiffeuse qui
participe elle aussi dans la catégorie
commerçant vous avez un beau petit sapin
de Noël avec le Père Noël donc l'esprit
de Noël est là quand même son sapin
truffé de petits détails en bois est là
pour mettre du beauotqueœur à ses
clients des gens malheureusement qui
sont seuls donc le fait de venir se
faire coiffer avec une belle déco tout
de suite on a envie de d'aller mieux au
vu du contexte cette mobilisation ne
laisse pas insensible le maire duet par
rapport à la période dans laquelle on
est qui est très difficile et autre avec
tout ce qui se passe à l'extérieur on
avait envie cette année de mettre un
petit peu de B cur j' sur commune de
faire ressortir que les gens de l'tiet
sont des gens qui aiment fêter les
choses que Noël est au cœur du moment
les lauréats du concours seront désignés
demain au marché de Noël du Tillet dans
la bonne humeur les vainqueurs se
verront remettre un chèque cadeau de 60
€ de quoi réinvestir dans les
illuminations du concours de l'an
prochain voilà on souhaite bonne chance
au Loréa Quentin très belles images déjà
attendu pr on espère qu'on saura qui est
le gagnant du coup oui c'est demain on
va parler de Noël euh dans la revue de
presse tout de
[Musique]
suite avant de parler de Noël on
commence avec pressocéans et les
Français qui boutent les vaccins contre
la grippe et le covid oui c'est ça ces
virus qui pourrait gâcher le réveillon
les fêtes pas de rué sur les vaccin l
Tom effectivement à la Une journale de
Nantes seul 7,6 % de la population en
Pays de la Loire est vacciné contre la
grippe 20 % des plus de 80 ans contre le
covid d'où cet appel des autorités de
santé à se faire vacciner au plus vite
d'autant qu'avec les fêtes les plus
jeunes vont se mélanger avec nos aînés
qui sont plus fragiles les autorités
sanitaires qui s'inquiètent également du
maigre respect des gestes barrière on va
donc surveiller la situation dans les
prochaines semaines les prochains jours
notamment la tension en milieu
hospitalier et donc si vous avez plus de
60 ans la vaccination est fortement
recommandée la dépêche revient sur cet
ado anglais retrouvé 6 ans après avoir
disparu ouais bâtit il a 17 ans
effectivement il était retrouvé en vie
mercredi 6 ans qu'il avait disparu avec
sa mère et son grand-père qui n'avait
pas la garde du jeune homme il faisait
partie d'une communauté spirituelle
itinérante révèle le journal de Toulouse
ce matin dans les pages intérieures
effectivement de la Dépêche du Midi on
lit le parcours du jeune aperçu au Maroc
et en Espagne la plupart du temps Alex
et ses proches auraient dormi dans des
caravanes des gites et même en tente
planté en pleine nature raconte le titre
ce matin la semaine le jeune homme cette
semaine le le jeun jeune homme a décidé
de quitter ce groupe il a marché pendant
4 jours dans la haute vallée de Laude
pour finir par croiser la route d'un
livreur sur une route départementale cet
incroyable périple est à lire dans le
journal ce matin allez Quentin
leberichon évidemment vous pouviez pas
ne pas parler de bourge qui était
désigné capitale européenne de la
culture en 2028 ça fait encore la une du
Berry Républicain voilà c'était mercredi
mais et maintenant au travail liton
effectivement ce matin dans le Journal
de Bourges et surtout quelle
transformation pour la préfecture du
Cher dans le journal on lit ce qui
devrait se passer c'est en ville d'ici
2028 la gare qui va être végétalisée par
une artiste et une agence d'architecte
un incubateur sur les les énergies
renouvlable tout ça ça va transformer la
ville d'ici 2028 Orian alors on va
parler de Noël mais d'abord de
l'inflation c'est dans l'Alsace voilà
l'Alsace le journal de mulouse qui fait
le point ce matin sur la hausse des prix
sur les produits traditionnels de Noël à
quelle CHU allez-vous être manger cette
année se demande le journal avec
l'exemple du foie gras qui devrait
augmenter de 5 % alors qu'il avait déjà
pris 10 à 15 % l'an dernier on termine
avec les marchés de Noël c'est une
tradition oui Arnaud il attendait voilà
comme dans cette revue de presse tous
les vendredis sur public Scéna
effectivement zoom sur un marché de Noël
qui est donc voilà un petit zoom qu'on
fait cette semaine à Montpellier avec
des chalets plein d'idées cadeau
pourquoi pas un nœud papillon pour une
touche d'élégance et d'originalité lon
dans le journal ou encore des tasses et
luminaires en céramique bref plein
d'idées dans ces marchés de Noël qu'on
adore à public c'est mais oui surtout
avec vous Quentin merci Quentin merci
beaucoup ARN la parlaire le savant
letique et le peuple l'enjeu du siècle
merci beaucoup AR mercique Deon d'avoir
été avec nous merci à tous de nous avoir
suivi on se retrouve lundi on parlera
évidemment longuement de la loi
immigration en attendant on vous
souhaite un très beau weekend dans les
marchés de
Noël